so far we've been assuming that the
discount rate isn't is it it it's the
same thing no matter how long of a
period we're talking about but we know
if you go to the bank and you say hey
Bank
I want to essentially invest in a
one-year CD they'll say okay one year CD
will give you two percent and you're
like well what if we give you the money
for two years so you can keep our money
or locked it in for even longer let's
say oh then we'll give you a little bit
more interest because you know what we
can do we have more flexibility for two
years we don't have to worry about
paying you so instead of giving you two
percent I don't know we'll give you
seven percent because we get to keep
your money for two years and maybe if
you say well you know I actually don't
even need my money for ten years so let
me give you the money for ten years and
say oh ten years if we get to keep your
money we'll give you twelve percent so
in general and this tends to be the case
although it's not always the case that
the longer that you you defer your money
or the the longer you lock up the money
the higher and interest rate you get so
the same thing is true when you're when
you're doing a discount rate oftentimes
you want to discount a a payment two
years out by a higher value than
something that's only one year out so
how do you do that so let's say the
risk-free rate so if you were to go out
and get a government bond if you were to
get a government bond the one year rate
the one year rate let's say that they're
only giving you one percent but let's
say that the two year rate the two year
rate they'll give you I don't know
they'll give you five percent so what
does that mean let's take the example so
that means you could take that hundred
dollars you could take that hundred
dollars and essentially lend it to the
federal government and in a year it will
give you one percent on it so that these
are annual rates so one percent 1.0 one
times one hundred that's just one
hundred and one dollars right fair
enough now your other option is you
could lock it in you could lend it to
the federal government for two years not
see your money and they say oh then
we're going to give you five percent a
year so then you're going to go five
percent a year so how much do you end up
with in two years well remember this is
an annual rate these are always quoted
in annual rates so if you're getting
five percent a year that's going to be
equal to let's do it on the calculator
that's going to be a hundred you're
after one year you're going to get 1.05
and then after two years you're going to
get 1.05 or you could view that as 100
times 1.05 squared so you'd have one
hundred ten dollars and twenty five
cents
you'd have one hundred and ten and
twenty five cents so you already see not
even doing any present value this is
actually you can almost view this as a
future value calculation if you take a
future value you already know that this
option is better than this option when
you have a when you have a kind of these
varying interest rates but anyway the
whole topic of this is to talk about
present values so let's do that so in
this circumstance what is the present
value of one hundred and ten dollars the
present will actually what is the
present value of the hundred dollars
well we always know that that's easy
that is a hundred dollars a present
value of a hundred dollars today is 100
dollars what is the present value of 110
so we take 110 and we're going to use
the two-year rate and discount twice
right and that makes sense because
essentially you're deferring your money
for two years you're not going to get
anything even a year from now so you're
deferring your money for two years so
you divide it by one so it's a 5% rate
1.05 squared and then that is equal to I
think that was our first problem right
so I'll just do it again 110 divided by
1.05 squared is equal to 99 dollar 77
cents right that was our first problem
and now this one is interesting right
the $20 you get today and this is just
as a sign that's very important when
you're doing this you know when they
talk about year one or year zero just
make sure is that today is that a year
from now because if it's a year from now
you would have to discount it right by
the one year interest rate if it's today
you don't discount it so anyway I I
clarified that now it's a little
ambiguous about that in the last few
videos but I clarified the $20 is now so
the present value of something giving
you today is the value of it so it's $20
plus $50 now $50 what do we use do we
use the one year rate or the two year
rate well of course we use the one year
rate right because you are you're not
deferring the pleasure of that $50 for
two years you're actually getting it in
one year so plus $50
/ one point the one-year rate / 1.0 1
plus $35 / the 2-year rate but this is
an annual rate so you have to discount
it twice divided by 1.05 squared let's
get the ti-85 out see you get 20 plus 50
divided by 1.0 1 + 35 divided by 1.05
squared is equal to 100 $1.25 100 and
$1.25 so notice these the actual payment
streams I did not change in any of the
three scenarios and let me just draw a
line between them because I got a little
bit messy so that was scenario 1 this is
scenario 2 and this is scenario 3 but in
scenario 1 because of the we use a 5%
discount rate for all you could say I
don't want to get used fancy words but
for all durations out we use a 5%
discount rate we saw that choice number
one was the best but then if the
discount rate were to change if we were
to change our assumption if we had a 2%
rate if for whatever reason we could
lend money to the federal government in
in the form of buying bonds from them we
could lend the federal government two
years over any time period at 2% or any
time period at 2% then all of a sudden
choice 2 became the best option and then
finally if we had this kind of this is
the most realistic scenario and even
though the math is fairly simple we're
actually doing fairly something fairly
sophisticated here when I had a
different when I had a different
discount rate for my one year out cash
flows and my two year out cash flows the
end and it was these exact numbers I had
to play with the numbers to get the
right result then all of a sudden choice
3 choice 3 was the was the best option
and so and and I'll leave it to you I
want you to think about why this
was better for choice three than it was
for choice two and and if you really
understand that then you I think are
starting to have a lot of intuition
about present values and frankly what
we're learning here is a discounted cash
flow right what is it discounted cash
flow I'm giving you I'm telling you I'm
giving a stream of cash flows twenty
dollars now fifty dollars a year from
now thirty-five dollars in two years and
you are essentially discounting them
back to get today's present value so
when someone says oh you know I can use
Excel to do a discounted cash flow
that's all they're doing they're making
some assumption about the discount rate
and they're just using this fairly you
know straightforward mathematics to get
the present value of those future cash
flows but it's it's a very powerful
technique because if you were to take if
you're going to Excel and you were to
say oh I have a business and based on my
assumptions and year one right now this
business gives me twenty dollars the
next year is going to give 50 dollars
the year after that's thirty five
dollars and you know this risk-free is a
big assumption but if it was risk for
you could discount it like that you say
oh this business is worth you know if
these are the interest rates this
business is worth a hundred and $1.25
you know that's what I'm willing to pay
for or I'm neutral if I could get it for
$90 that's a good deal for me that's all
that this kind of cash flow is but the
the big learning from this is how
dependent the present value of a a
future of future payments are on that
your discount rate assumption the
discount rate assumption is everything
in finance and and this is this is where
finance really diverges from a lot of
other fields especially in the sciences
there really is no correct answer it's
all assumption driven all of these
discounted cash flows and all these
models they're really just to help you
understand the dynamics of things and
frankly and this happens a lot in the
real world of finance if you ever become
a an analyst in the investment at an
investment bank you'll probably do this
yourself but you can almost justify any
present value by picking the right
discount rate and actually the whole
topic of how do you decide on the right
discount rate because we assumed
risk-free right everything is risk for
you're guaranteed these payments but we
know in the real world if you're
investing in if you're investing in
pets.com and they tell you that they're
going to pay these cash flows to you
that's
risk free there's some risk implicit in
that so actually most of finance and
most of well yeah and portfolio theory
and modern finance is based on figuring
out that discount rate and it's it and
that is the crux of everything because
if we see that that completely changes
which of these options is the best but
anyway I don't want to confuse you too
much what you have already is a very
powerful tool that if you can think of a
discount rate you can make a very
rational comparison between three or you
know or 10 or whatever different types
of payments and this is actually really
useful you don't realize how many how
many things in the world are like this
right you could you know these these
college these you know college payment
schemes where you pay some company you
know twenty five dollars a year for
twenty years and then in in year twenty
one they're willing to pay for your
college tuition or your kids college
tuition that's a you could figure out
what that really is worth how much money
are they making off of you by taking a
discounted cash flow and of course if
you're paying out these become negative
numbers and when they pay you it becomes
a positive number anyway maybe I'll do
that in a couple of videos because I
think that's a fairly useful thing to be
able to analyze see you in the next
video